ragazzi mi hanno invitato a casa di
amici però in guardia oggi vi farò
vedere come questa casa e vi porterò con
me è una cosa molto tranquilla quindi
tranquilli guardate i video anche con i
vostri fratellini piccoli c'è niente di
tranquilli c'è niente di strano
quella visione allora capiamoci questa è
una cosa che non va bene affette allora
io non so dove sono ciò una torcia che
punta enter the manor porca vacca mi
muovo così la sto male
va bene enter the manor c'è una tavola
luisa sono un nano che carino a saperlo
prima
enter the man ormai entrate l'enac ha
detto no giampy bruttissimo solo dei
core rinunci di udine di mai
no non ci giocare ho sentito la voce
nelle orecchie che vorrei morire allora
l'importante capirci dove stiamo andando
salve è che bella casa se ne guarda al
seme di giorno e bellissima di notte fa
ho sentito delle cose ma non
approfondirò permesso ma avete fatto le
porte per giganti o sono io che sono
sempre un anno nei giochi in guardavo si
è chiusa come siete ma sta torcia qua è
finta non illuminato da torce ora torcia
rotta
grazie mi hanno pagato meno male che va
a cagà salve o le torce che non
funzionano se me ne dai una che funziona
sono più contento visto che stava in un
horror braccio e un quadro di saab
alcuno mago è vero è uguale angelo c'è
anche un grammofono di stick che maria
che è successo qualcosa mi sono pagato
un po sotto però non fa niente andiamo
avanti perché noi siamo delle persone
temerarie e le persone temerari e sapete
non hanno paura le persone temerari di
persone temerari e vanno avanti il
pericolo li spaventa la torcia iniziato
a funzionare gianpi ha iniziato a
funzionare la torcia perché ha capito
che se una persona temeraria sono forte
io non ho paura che non ha paura di voi
io non ho paura del sapere dei libri non
ho paura sporco demonio morto ieri era
un pipistrello tranquillo ci è passato
anche batman a questa questa cosa non
succede niente lavora è tutta nel
cervello che alle volte non ho né niente
cervello niente paura come pietro
let's go my boys verso l'infinito aprì
le porte che me ne frega le porte si
aprono davanti a me perché io non ho
paura giampiero cessata da in questo
posto
possano i quadri
roba che harry potter i confronti un
novellino io me la sento un sacco oggi
me la sento da morire me la sento perché
una persona come me deve saper
combattere le proprie paure perché io ho
fatto l'esame di maturità e oltre quello
ve lo dico io ragazzi non c'è niente
quello è il peggio non c'è leva militare
che regga non c'è horror noir che regga
questa è una strada senza uscita e
meglio ora lordi insegno ragazzi che le
strade senza uscita
non sono mai una cosa ottima però vabbè
non succede niente allora stiamo
scendendo all'inferno amici miei stiamo
scendendo all'inferno
se non dovessi tornare ti ho voluto bene
vade retro porta così titola i topi ei
sono da piero sono qui da te sei
tranquillo
non c'è niente non succede niente non
succede niente nel sociale intransigente
non succede niente
mingardi un leviosa wingardium leviosa
non c'è niente
saleh è stato bruttissimo cosa c'è
ma cos'è un tiro e vabbè ma basta basta
aprire porte
chi è che il mora che chiude la porta
orlando che è il nostro quadro fu salve
mi piace perché questa zona è molto più
allegra di quella di prima tu pensa come
la volée di prima ma è una cucina da
tranquilli non avete visto la mia tra
l'altro topo morto
la carne è scaduta credo non so se vado
voglio controllare la data di scadenza
effettiva secondo me è scaduta ve lo
dico io
io occhio per queste cose allora vedo
già annabelle dentro st porta quindi non
so qual è il massimo
caccia vacca
allora non so no no ti rimando all'asilo
porca vacca
ecco schifo via via via via via via di
qua via
[Musica]
gianpi ho dei problemi
ecco questa è l'incarnazione della mia
ex molto molto simile quando ci siamo
lasciati
e andata così comunque è un gioco
veramente realistico ve lo garantisco
se riuscisse a trovare la porta d'uscita
sarebbe ancora meglio posso uscire dalla
finestra
ma c'è un'altra porta cosa sporca di una
pacchia morta
chi è che porta in faccia ho preso meno
male che non ce l'ha non c'è la fisicità
nei gior
mi fa piacere avere tanti amici oggi già
salve quelle vie prof di matematica ma
lo ricorda avuto almeno parti matematica
testo che mi segue quella invece la
profili informatica ancora peggio senta
lei mi scusi non è che può fare come se
fosse a casa sua qua neanche tu puoi
smettila di fare la bambina è stata nato
io non l'ho detto già p
ci sono dei problemi di magnetismo in
questa camera
io non ho figli sono scappati in messico
apposta smettetela quanto quanto ci fai
da 1 1000 questa volta si apre quanto ci
fate a davvero non sia aperta che strana
la crisi
non mi sento di poter continuare ragazzi
c'è una porta più bella delle altre
forse non riusciamo ad uscire forse no
porta all'inferno anche questa però
vabbè persone o fatti ben i dettagli il
suo gioco c'è enciclopedia filosofia a
questo sì che è un horror carino
comunque una canzone del 2000 poteva
temere parlare non sono tipo
rihanna è un consiglio per il signor non
sbattere porta non sbattere per cortesia
senta signora
se però state calmi giampiero non è
cascato un mobile lookup una mia grande
sporco demonio scusa non volevo
insultarti lo so che sei tra queste mura
e nel senso mi è venuto spontaneo mi
sembrano i tempi di quando prendevo il
pullman la mattina prenderla come lo
guarda l'ansia era la stessa
i jam scherano gli stessi quando vedevi
le facce dei ragazzi la mattina che bei
ricordi
ho avuto una bella infanzia apriti porta
scolastica la smettiamo di far lievitare
il mobilio e non arriverà un punto check
point qualcosa continuiamo così da vita
cento maiala oh che bello
stavo scherzando stavo scherzando non in
casa scherzavo non ho ben capito no no
no oddio che vomito ragazzo male ma la
lega mi sento come dare tantissimo che
brutta roba in boulard sta roba harry
bile mi sento girare tantissimo siamo
arrivati al checkmate ringraziando il
cielo sale c'è poi in the easy
ok è un checkpoint molto brutto però è
un c'è poi qualcosa mi dice che non ho
proprio voglia di passare queste porte
però che l'avevo vista all'ikea l'altro
giorno ma quando di cuore come moio
morto
[Applauso]
used by detto anche tua sorella
se non vuoi metterti a take that the
manor e finito così dio ti ringrazio
anche è finito così è stato molto
divertente ve lo giuro
quindi ragazzi allora non so se avete
mai visto tipo il programma di mtv colo
dove vi fanno vedere la casa bella
grossa
ecco prossima volta io farò la stessa
cosa i noir nel senso vi faccio vedere
bene bene alla casa horror e poi mi
seguite
se avete voglia io credo che questo
possa essere uno step per il futuro
soprattutto per i bambini che seguono
questi video non andate dalla mamma a
dire per poi è un casino non riuscite
più a vedere i video di telephone
andiamo ad abitare lì io spero
tantissimo che questo video vi sia
piaciuto
spero di non aver perso più di tot anni
di vita con facendo questo video perché
già ne rimangono pochi con tutti gli
horror che ho fatto si sa mai nella vita
però va bene sono morto letteralmente
dentro e fuori però spero che vi sia
piaciuto e quindi che lasciate dai
consensi sono sempre fischiate ci
vediamo ad un prossimo appartamento che
mi farò visitare o forse no da ragazzi
[Musica]